and that being said let's get into that
first story we got it from npr
now i used npr on purpose as the source
of this because we're going to rag on
them later
biden acknowledges his team should have
done more covid testing earlier now
that's the headline but the point of
this story is marking the end of his
first year in office with a long
wide-ranging formal press conference
biden said it had been a year of
challenges but also a year of enormous
progress citing stats on vaccinations
job creation and cuts to child poverty
the real story here is that joe biden
had a press conference of course npr
likes to soften the blow for the man
because right now on twitter 25th
amendment is trending now here's where
it gets funny
initially it started trending because
people critical of joe biden which
includes the independent uh not
unaffiliated voter and republican voters
moderates liberals post liberals
conservatives libertarians they're all
basically saying yo i think something's
wrong with joe biden he's saying a bunch
of crazy stuff he's like inviting war
with with russia and ukraine and then it
gets taken over by
the left who starts calling people
maggots
screaming the 25th amendment and then
they just start showing you know donald
trump speaking and other stuff
i think the reality is
there's one clip in particular that
really exemplifies this someone asked
joe biden directly why it is that so
many people think he's in cognitive
decline and his response was i i have no
idea and it's funny because that's
actually the correct answer joe biden
has no idea right well so so i find this
i find this fascinating that we're
finally getting this press conference
from joe biden
and that people are using it as an
opportunity to basically be like this
man should not be president
i mean i i think people came to that
realization as soon as he came into
office i think people came to that
realization when he wasn't even running
a campaign and the media was running it
for him but there's a lot of major
bombshells in this kind of press
conference that he released
real quick i like that you called it a
kind of press conference yeah i mean
yeah i mean he was there for two hours
took 24 questions let's admit that's
that's sort of impressive for biden
especially at his age but he talked
about a lot of nonsense he was
congratulating himself on his
afghanistan pull out he said that
america is making enormous progress
meanwhile we have record coveted cases
the united states government right now
under his administration is getting 400
million and 95 masks over 400 million
covet tests when the united kingdom is
literally getting rid of their vax
passport system and mask mandates what
he's doing is the complete opposite of
what should be doing and let's not also
forget he pretty much invited putin to
invade ukraine which is an absolutely
huge bombshell with a lot of significant
ramifications
and everything to me look
biden should fire every single person at
white house immediately and i'll tell
you why the reason why they went to this
press conference because tomorrow is the
one year anniversary of his inauguration
so what they're doing from a strategic
thing in their minds not very smart is
they want to get ahead of it i could
just see him in the briefing room now
with peppermint patty there saying hey
we're going to have this one-year
anniversary we got to frame the
headlines let's go out there and talk
about everything great that we're doing
so joe biden gets out there and
literally assumes a responsibility for
every malady that is affecting the
united states right now so basically he
gets up there and he lists everything
going wrong here's what we're doing
about it we're making great doing
progress so oh they're again they're
going to have some headlines for their
one year anniversary tomorrow i don't
think it's the headlines they were
looking for i don't know though you
think the media is actually going to be
fair and criticize joe biden so i i got
to tell you this it's here's the thing
you got to keep out keep mine about
reporters is they're basically
uh uh
well they're they're alligators right
they gotta eat and so they are it's a
matter of time for how how quickly they
turn on someone but they're gonna turn
on you i mean they you know the easiest
way to to not get eaten is not look like
food well joe biden right now looks like
a big juicy cheeseburger
people are angry uh i can't remember who
was saying it but they were like when
people go to the grocery store they're
angry when they see their products are
skyrocketing in cost they're angry when
they see their gas prices they're angry
i see these memes man there's a meme of
uh somebody all it is is someone pumping
gas and it was like in 2019 or something
and it was like a dollar seventy and i
was just like wow
gas was under two bucks i remember at
that point you know i was driving and i
saw the gas prices and i was shocked
because when i was 18 and working in
chicago
the gas prices were hitting two dollars
and it was a big deal and now here we
are wonder trump and it's back under two
bucks and i was like is that crazy how
is is that and now the gas prices are
skyrocketing in california what was that
like nine bucks in one once was it like
a while ago or was it seven i thought it
was i thought it was more like six but
you might be right there was like one
particular town where it got got like
really really high maybe maybe nine was
i thought everyone drove prius is out
there the people still get gasoline and
teslas yeah guilty and uh out here in
the middle of nowhere it's been in like
the three to like mid three dollars
range people go to the gas station
they're angry
i'll tell you this from pr standpoint
joe biden coming out and reminding
everybody of that is probably not a good
idea but to your point you're right i
think journalists are going to be like
hey a lot of people are really pissed
off why everything happening around them
hey joe biden talked about it there's
our angle the other thing to keep in
mind too is that ratings and
subscriptions are down for everywhere in
the mainstream media with no trump trump
basically he created
one of the industries he helped the most
was the mainstream media he gave
everybody ratings boost right now all
the subscriptions ratings are down you
saw was at cnn's down 90 whatever it is
so they have to turn because if it's
just softball city they're not going to
get any ratings even look on the drive
out here i was even listening to fake
news cnn and even they were turning on
him and it was amazing to hear you know
the jake tappers and the wolf blitzers
and all these folks being critical of
biden you know they're saying you know
clean up on was the one line i think
dana bash used was clean up on the state
department aisle or something like that
with the ukraine thing i mean they have
uh they see those ratings down ninety
percent you better believe they're going
to turn on joe biden what are we at 29
democrats announcing their retirement
was that it or was it 27
i don't know i don't know those exact
numbers but but my point is just real
quick
even the democrat politic democratic
politicians in congress are starting to
jump [ __ ] yeah there's it's only so long
for those two dudes to hold up bernie
right
until the weight gets too strong for
them the weekend at bernie's i'm making
a reference
no no no i'm making a reference the
weekend at bernie's great movie classic
movie about a dead guy that two guys
were carrying around to be alive i'm not
going to spoil the plot for you
definitely
a 30 year old movie all right he gets
elected in 2020
exactly by the corporate media the two
people holding him up is the
bureaucratic corrupt system and of
course the corporate media journalist
that weight of bernie is getting very
heavy and they're starting to let go
because it's too absurd not to call out
biden on his failures for him to stand
and talk to the american people and say
what he did in afghanistan was a success
is absolutely crazy he blamed everything
because he wasn't able to pass the build
back better bill he blamed by the way
the new hampshire governor for that he
said he the new hampshire governor is
one of the biggest roadblocks to build
back better which would have solved
everything no no no no buildback better
would have created more government which
he has been implementing and using which
has been
absolutely eviscerating our current way
of life destroying any kind of wealth
destroying any kind of future young
people have in this country because when
you look at his policies these are the
policies of the corporatist the most
corrupt special interests and lobbyists
in washington dc that are absolutely
getting away with murder and able to get
away with whatever they want under his
administration which he's acting like a
larger puppet for as he's really a
representative of them let's let me read
this we got uh charlie spearing says
quote i didn't over promise says joe
biden says he outperformed in his first
year josh hawley responds store shelves
are empty prices are soaring real wages
are declining american cities are
engulfed in violence the border is
controlled by the cartels and parents
are treated as terrorists while actual
terrorists go free when do the dems
seriously consider the 25th amendment
and then what kamala harris
that's that's a scary notion you know
one of the things to tell you a sure
sign
in politics when uh someone who's in
office or candidate when they're losing
when their idea to turn something around
is all tactics as opposed to strategy
now this can a little bit nuanced by
putting my politics hat back on for a
moment here so joe biden
in addition to listing out everything
going around the country his grand
strategy was to get out of the white
house i have to get out of the white
house i have to tour the country i gotta
go talk to people between covid and
between things going on here in
washington i'm not getting face to face
if i do this things are going to turn
around that's a tactic that's a small
thing like hey we're going to hold press
conferences on wednesdays or i'm going
to go out and we're going to he blamed
it on the communications effort said we
have to talk to people better okay when
you're talking about stuff as a
president like that of the president
united states you know the whole thing's
disaster that's why i said clean
peppermint patty circle back they all
need to be fired because so disastrous
the headlines tomorrow are just a
nightmare and just to be clear
peppermint patty is jen sackey right yes
yes who's actually she's somewhat
decently nice but
you know it's fair that's funny you
called her that i was fair and political
and like if you're discussing changing
strategy instead of changing tactics
you're talking about more of a global a
general
uh
behaviors like how are we going to deal
with climate change as opposed to
uh
so or is climate change what you know
how how big of a deal is climate change
like that would be more of a strategy
conversation right so here's here's the
reality for biden is that biden has one
speed today he talked about he tried to
he literally said what this was a buried
line i think i posted this on getter he
said that we have to contrast uh against
the other side more he has a one speed
and that's to go and say i'm not trump
and so usually what happens in election
is joe biden says i'm not trump he ends
up winning and then the first year
second year you don't have someone to
say i'm not trump your your ratings go
down and then you get closer to the next
election then you have a chance to
contrast against someone else that's the
only way that biden has a chance of
succeeding is saying i'm not trump we
saw him pivot to that he couldn't even
say anything negative about mitch
mcconnell all of you guys saw that he
was like oh i'm friends with mitch
mcconnell he's great but the strategy
thing is joe biden has to go and take it
right now he's playing the whack-a-mole
with all these little things a strategic
change would be to go and say rather
than getting mired in all the hill
legislation i'm gonna go out there and
launch a new initiative and get behind
and say uh this administration is about
you know the chicken in every pot or you
know this is about uh you know helping
this group of voters or something but we
need so strategically or he says look
right now we're on a fight against the
ccp or a fight against putin and russia
some kind of strategic shift from
domestic to uh international that's a
strategic shift but just saying i'm
going to get out and go talk to people
around the country
that's do you think anyone who's pumping
up and paying five or six dollars a
gallon for gas is going to give a you
know what he's going to get out of the
white house more no
no not at all it's just
without trump
they really don't have anything and
that's that was
even during the election now we're
getting into 2022
and it looks like with democrats
retiring they see the writing on the
wall the media you mentioned some of
them now turning on joe biden they see
the writing on the wall thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you